Good morning.
Today we're going to talk about
it a balanced search structure,
so a data structure that
maintains a dynamic set subject
to insertion,
deletion, and search called
skip lists.
So, I'll call this a dynamic
search structure because it's a
data structure.
It supports search,
and it's dynamic,
meaning insert and delete.
So, what other dynamic search
structures do we know,
just for sake of comparison,
and to wake everyone up?
Shut them out,
efficient, I should say,
also good, logarithmic time per
operation.
So, this is a really easy
question to get us off the
ground.
You've seen them all in the
last week, so it shouldn't be so
hard.
Treap, good.
On the problems that we saw
treaps.
That's, in some sense,
the simplest dynamic search
structure you can get from first
principles because all we needed
was a bound on a randomly
constructed binary search tree.
And then treaps did well.
So, that was sort of the first
one you saw depending on when
you did your problem set.
What else?
Charles?
Red black trees,
good answer.
So, that was exactly one week
ago.
I hope you still remember it.
They have guaranteed log n
performance.
So, this was an expected bound.
This was a worst-case order log
n per operation,
insert, delete,
and search.
And, there was one more for
those who want to recitation on
Friday: B trees,
good.
And, by B trees,
I also include two-three trees,
two-three-four trees,
and all those guys.
So, if B is a constant,
or if you want your B trees
knows a little bit cleverly,
that these have guaranteed
order log n performance,
so, worst case,
order log n.
So, you should know this.
These are all balanced search
structures.
They are dynamic.
They support insertions and
deletions.
They support searches,
finding a given key.
And if you don't find the key,
you find its predecessor and
successor pretty easily in all
of these structures.
If you want to augment some
data structure,
you should think about which
one of these is easiest to
augment, as in Monday's lecture.
So, the question I want to pose
to you is supposed I gave you
all a laptop right now,
which would be great.
Then I asked you,
in order to keep this laptop
you have to implement one of
these data structures,
let's say, within this class
hour.
Do you think you could do it?
How many people think you could
do it?
A couple people,
a few people,
OK, all front row people,
good.
I could probably do it.
My preference would be B trees.
They're sort of the simplest in
my mind.
This is without using the
textbook.
This would be a closed book
exam.
I don't have enough laptops to
do it, unfortunately.
So, B trees are pretty
reasonable.
Deletion, you have to remember
stealing from a sibling and
whatnot.
So, deletions are a bit tricky.
Red black trees,
I can never remember it.
I'd have to look it up,
or re-derive the three cases.
treaps are a bit fancy.
So, that would take a little
while to remember exactly how
those work.
You'd have to solve your
problem set again,
if you don't have it memorized.
Skip lists, on the other hand,
are a data structure you will
never forget,
and something you can implement
within an hour,
no problem.
I've made this claim a couple
times before,
and I always felt bad because I
had never actually done it.
So, this morning,
I implemented skip lists,
and it took me ten minutes to
implement a linked list,
and 30 minutes to implement
skip lists.
And another 30 minutes
debugging them.
There you go.
It can be done.
Skip lists are really simple.
And, at no point writing the
code did I have to think,
whereas every other structure I
would have to think.
There was one moment when I
thought, ah, how do I flip a
coin?
That was the entire amount of
thinking.
So, skip lists are a randomized
structure.
Let's add in another adjective
here, and let's also add in
simple.
So, we have a simple,
efficient, dynamic,
randomized search structure:
all those things together.
So, it's sort of like treaps
and that the bound is only a
randomized bound.
But today, we're going to see a
much stronger bound than an
expectation bound.
So, in particular,
skip lists will run in order
log n expected time.
So, the running time for each
operation will be order log n in
expectation.
But, we're going to prove a
much stronger result that their
order log n, with high
probability.
So, this is a very strong
claim.
And it means that the running
time of each operation,
the running time of every
operation is order log n almost
always in a certain sense.
Why don't I foreshadow that?
So, it's something like,
the probability that it's order
log n is at least one minus one
over some polynomial,
and n.
And, you get to set the
polynomial however large you
like.
So, what this basically means
is that almost all the time,
you take your skip lists,
you do a polynomial number of
operations on it,
because presumably you are
running a polynomial time
algorithm that using this data
structure.
Do polynomial numbers of
inserts, delete searches,
every single one of them will
take order log n time,
almost guaranteed.
So this is a really strong
bound on the tail of the
distribution.
The mean is order log n.
That's not so exciting.
But, in fact,
almost all of the weight of
this probability distribution is
right around the log n,
just tiny little epsilons,
very tiny probabilities you
could be bigger than log n.
So that's where we are going.
This is a data structure by
Pugh] in 1989.
This is the most recent.
Actually, no,
sorry, treaps are more recent.
They were like '93 or so,
but a fairly recent data
structure for just insert,
delete, search.
And, it's very simple.
You can derive it if you don't
know anything about data
structures, well,
almost nothing.
Now, analyzing that the
performance is log n,
that, of course,
takes our sophistication.
But the data structure itself
is very simple.
We're going to start from
scratch.
Suppose you don't know what a
red black tree is.
You don't know what a B tree
is.
Suppose you don't even know
what a tree is.
What is the simplest data
structure for storing a bunch of
items for storing a dynamic set?
A list, good,
a linked list.
Now, suppose that it's a sorted
linked list.
So, I'm going to be a little
bit fancier there.
So, if you have a linked list
of items, here it is,
maybe we'll make it doubly
linked just for kicks,
how long does it take to search
in a sorted linked list?
Log n is one answer.
n is the other answer.
Which one is right?
n is the right answer.
So, even though it's sorted,
we can't do binary search
because we don't have
random-access into a linked
list.
So, suppose I'm only given a
pointer to the head.
Otherwise, I'm assuming it's an
array.
So, in a sorted array you can
search in log n.
Sorted linked list:
you've still got to scan
through the darn thing.
So, theta n,
worst case search.
Not so good,
but if we just try to improve
it a little bit,
we will discover skip lists
automatically.
So, this is our starting point:
sorted linked lists,
data n time.
And, I'm not going to think too
much about insertions and
deletions for the moment.
Let's just get search better,
and then we'll worry about
dates.
Updates are where randomization
will come in.
Search: pretty easy idea.
So, how can we make a linked
list better?
Suppose all we know about our
linked lists.
What can I do to make it
faster?
This is where you need a little
bit of innovation,
some creativity.
More links: that's a good idea.
So, I do try to maybe add
pointers to go a couple steps
ahead.
If I had log n pointers,
I could do all powers of two
ahead.
That's a pretty good search
structure.
Some people use that;
like, some peer-to-peer
networks use that idea.
But that's a little too fancy
for me.
Ah, good.
You could try to build a tree
on this linear structure.
That's essentially where we're
going.
So, you could try to put
pointers to, like,
the middle of the list from the
roots.
So, you search between either
here.
You point to the median,
so you can compare against the
median, and know whether you
should go in the first half or
the second half that's
definitely on the right track,
also a bit too sophisticated.
Another list:
yes.
Yes, good.
So, we are going to use two
lists.
That's sort of the next
simplest thing you could do.
OK, and as you suggested,
we could maybe have pointers
between them.
So, maybe we have some elements
down here, some of the elements
up here.
We want to have pointers
between the lists.
OK, it gets a little bit crazy
in how exactly you might do
that.
But somehow,
this feels good.
So this is one linked list:
L_1.
This is another linked list:
L_2.
And, to give you some
inspiration, I want to give you,
so let's play a game.
The game is,
what is this sequence?
So, the sequence is 14.
If you know the answer,
shout it out.
Anyone yet? OK, it's tricky.
It's a bit of a small class,
so I hope someone knows the
answer.
How many TA's know the answer?
Just a couple,
OK, if you're looking at the
slides, probably you know the
answer.
That's cheating.
OK, I'll give you a hint.
It is not a mathematical
sequence.
This is a real-life sequence.
Yeah?
Yeah, and what city?
New York, yeah,
this is the 7th Ave line.
This is my favorite subway line
in New York.
But, what's a cool feature of
the New York City subway?
OK, it's a skip list.
Good answer.
[LAUGHTER] Indeed it is.
Skip lists are so practical.
They've been implemented in the
subway system.
How cool is that?
OK, Boston subway is pretty
cool because it's the oldest
subway definitely in the United
States, maybe in the world.
New York is close,
and it has other nice features
like it's open 24 hours.
That's a definite plus,
but it also has this feature of
express lines.
So, it's a bit of an
abstraction,
but the 7th Ave line has
essentially two kinds of cars.
These are street numbers by the
way.
This is, Penn Station,
Times Square,
and so on.
So, there are essentially two
lines.
There's the express line which
goes 14, to 34,
to 42, to 72,
to 96.
And then, there's the local
line which stops at every stop.
And, they accomplish this with
four sets of tracks.
So, I mean, the express lines
have their own dedicated track.
If you want to go to stop 59
from, let's say,
Penn Station,
well, let's say from lower west
side, you get on the express
line.
You jump to 42 pretty quickly,
and then you switch over to the
local line, and go on to 59 or
wherever I said I was going.
OK, so this is express and
local lines, and we can
represent that with a couple of
lists.
We have one list,
sure, we have one list on the
bottom, so leave some space up
here.
This is the local line,
L_2, 34, 42,
50, 59, 66, 72,
79, and so on.
And then we had the express
line on top, which only stops at
14, 34, 42, 72,
and so on.
I'm not going to redraw the
whole list.
You get the idea.
And so, what we're going to do
is put links between in the
local and express lines,
wherever they happen to meet.
And, that's our two linked list
structure.
So, that's what I actually
meant what I was trying to draw
some picture.
Now, this has a property that
in one list, the bottom list,
every element occurs.
And the top list just copies
some of those elements.
And we're going to preserve
that property.
So, L_2 stores all the
elements, and L_1 stores some
subset.
And, it's still open which ones
we should store.
That's the one thing we need to
think about.
But, our inspiration is from
the New York subway system.
OK, there, that the idea.
Of course, we're also going to
use more than two lists.
OK, we also have links.
Let's say it links between
equal keys in L_1 and L_2.
Good.
So, just for the sake of
completeness,
and because we will need this
later, let's talk about searches
before we worry about how these
lists are actually constructed.
Of course, if I wanted that
board.
So, if you want to search for
an element, x,
what do you do?
Well, this is the taking the
subway algorithm.
And, suppose you always start
in the upper left corner of the
subway system,
if you're always in the lower
west side, 14th St,
and I don't know exactly where
that is, but more or less,
somewhere down at the bottom of
Manhattan.
And, you want to go to a
particular station like 59.
Well, you'd stay on the express
line as long as you can because
it happens that we started on
the express line.
And then, you go down.
And then you take the local
line the rest of the way.
That's clearly the right thing
to do if you always start in the
top left corner.
So, I'm going to write that
down in some kind of an
algorithm because we will be
generalizing it.
It's pretty obvious at this
point.
It will remain obvious.
So, I want to walk right in the
top list until that would go too
far.
So, you imagine giving someone
directions on the subway system
they've never been on.
So, you say,
OK, you start at 14th.
Take the express line,
and when you get to 72nd,
you've gone too far.
Go back one,
and then go down to the local
line.
It's really annoying
directions.
But this is what an algorithm
has to do because it's never
taken the subway before.
So, it's going to check,
so let's do it here.
So, suppose I'm aiming for 59.
So, I started 14,
say the first thing I do is go
to 34.
Then from there,
I go to 42.
Still good because 59 is bigger
than 42.
I go right again.
I say, oops,
72 is too big.
That was too far.
So, I go back to where it just
was.
Then I go down and then I keep
going right until I find the
element that I want,
or discover that it's not in
the bottom list because bottom
list has everyone.
So, that's the algorithm.
Stop when going right would go
too far, and you discover that
with a comparison.
Then you walk down to L_2.
And then you walk right in L_2
until you find x,
or you find something greater
than x, in which case x is
definitely not on your list.
And you found the predecessor
and successor,
which may be your goal.
If you didn't find where x was,
you should find where it would
go if it were there,
because then maybe you could
insert there.
We're going to use this
algorithm in insertion.
OK, but that search:
pretty easy at this point.
Now, what we haven't discussed
is how fast the search algorithm
is, and it depends,
of course, which elements we're
going to store in L_1,
which subset of elements should
go in L_1.
Now, in the subway system,
you probably put all the
popular stations in L_1.
But here, we want worst-case
performance.
So, we don't have some
probability distribution on the
nodes.
We just like every node to be
accessed sort of as quickly as
possible, uniformly.
So, we want to minimize the
maximum time over all queries.
So, any ideas what we should do
with L_1?
Should I put all the nodes of
L_1 in the beginning?
OK, it's a strict subset.
Suppose I told you what the
size of L_1 was.
I can tell you,
I could afford to build this
many express stops.
How should you distribute them
among the elements of L_2?
Uniformly, good.
So, what nodes,
sorry, what keys,
let's say, go in L_1?
Well, definitely the best thing
to do is to spread them out
uniformly, OK,
which is definitely not what
the 7th Ave line looks like.
But, let's imagine that we
could reengineer everything.
So, we're going to try to space
these things out a little bit
more.
So, 34 and 42nd are way too
close.
We'll take a few more stops.
And, now we can start to
analyze things.
OK, as a function of the length
of L_1.
So, the cost of a search is now
roughly, so, I want a function
of the length of L_1,
and the length of L_2,
which is all the elements,
n.
What is the cost of the search
if I spread out all the elements
in L_1 uniformly?
Yeah?
Right, the total number of
elements in the top lists,
plus the division between the
bottom and the top.
So, I'll write the length of
L_1 plus the length of L_2
divided by the length of L_1.
OK, this is roughly,
I mean, there's maybe a plus
one or so here because in the
worst case, I have to search
through all of L_1 because the
station I could be looking for
could be the max.
OK, and maybe I'm not lucky,
and the max is not on the
express line.
So then, I have to go down to
the local line.
And how many stops will I have
to go on the local line?
Well, L_1 just evenly
partitions L_2.
So this is the number of
consecutive stations between two
express stops.
So, I take the express,
possibly this long,
but I take the local possibly
this long.
And, this is an L_2.
And there is,
plus, a constant,
for example,
go walking down.
But that's basically the number
of nodes that I visit.
So, I'd like to minimize this
function.
Now, L_2, I'm going to call
that n because that's the total
number of elements.
L_1, I can choose to be
whatever I want.
So, let's go over here.
So, I want to minimize L_1 plus
n over L_1.
And I get to choose L_1.
Now, I could differentiate
this, set it to zero,
and go crazy.
Or, I could realize that,
I mean, that's not hard.
But, that's a little bit too
fancy for me.
So, I could say,
well, this is clearly best when
L_1 is small.
And this is clearly best when
L_1 is large.
So, there's a trade-off there.
And, the trade-off will be
roughly minimized up to constant
factors when these two terms are
equal.
That's when I have pretty good
balance between the two ends of
the trade-off.
So, this is up to constant
factors.
I can let L_1 equal n over L_1,
OK, because at most I'm losing
a factor of two there when they
happen to be equal.
So now, I just solve this.
This is really easy.
This is (L_1)^2 equals n.
So, L_1 is the square root of
n.
OK, so the cost that I'm
getting over here,
L_1 plus L_2 over L_1 is the
square root of n plus n over
root n, which is,
again, root n.
So, I get two root n.
So, search cost,
and I'm caring about the
constant here,
because it will matter in a
moment.
Two square root of n:
I'm not caring about the
additive constant,
but the multiplicative constant
I care about.
OK, that seems good.
We started with a linked list
that searched in n time,
theta n time per operation.
Now we have two linked lists,
search and theta root n time.
It seems pretty good.
This is what the structure
looks like.
We have root n guys here.
This is in the local line.
And, we have one express stop
which represents that.
But we have another root n
values in the local line.
And we have one express stop
that represents that.
And these two are linked,
and so on.
Well, I should put some dot,
dot, dots in there.
OK, so each of these chunks has
length root n,
and the number of
representatives up here is
square root of n.
The number of express stops is
So clearly, things are balanced
now.
I search for,
at most, square root of n up
here.
Then I search in one of these
lists for, at most,
square root of n.
So, every search takes,
at most, two root n.
Cool, what should we do next?
So, again, ignore insertions
and deletions.
I want to make searches faster
because square root of n is not
so hot as we know.
Sorry?
More lines.
Let's add a super express line,
or another linked list.
OK, this was two.
Why not do three?
So, we started with a sorted
linked list.
Then we went to two.
This gave us two square root of
n.
Now, I want three sorted linked
lists.
I didn't pluralize here.
Any guesses what the running
time might be?
This is just guesswork.
Don't think.
From two square root of n,
you would go to,
sorry?
Two square root of two,
fourth root of n?
That's on the right track.
Both the constant and the root
change, but not quite so
fancily.
Three times the cubed root:
good.
Intuition is very helpful here.
It doesn't matter what the
right answer is.
Use your intuition.
You can prove that.
It's not so hard.
You now have three lists,
and what you want to balance
are at the length of the top
list, the ratio between the top
two lists, and the ratio between
the bottom two lists.
So, you want these three to
multiply out to n,
because the top times the ratio
times the ratio:
that has to equal n.
And, so that's where you get
the cubed root of n.
Each of these should be equal.
So, you set them because the
cost is the sum of those three
things.
So, you set each of them to
cubed root of n,
and there are three of them.
OK, check it at home if you
want to be more sure.
Obviously, we want a few more.
So, let's think about k sorted
lists.
k sorted lists will be k times
the k'th root of n.
You probably guessed that by
now.
So, what should we set k to?
I don't want the exact minimum.
What's a good value for k?
Should I set it to n?
n's kind of nice,
because the n'th root of n is
just one.
Now that's n.
So, this is why I cared about
the lead constant because it's
going to grow as I add more
lists.
What's the biggest reasonable
value of k that I could use?
Log n, because I have a k out
there.
I certainly don't want to use
more than log n.
So, log n times the log n'th
root, and this is a little hard
to draw of n.
Now, what is the log n'th root
of n?
That's what you're all thinking
about.
What is the log n'th root of n
minus two?
It's one of these good
questions whose answer is?
Oh man.
Remember the definition of
root?
OK, the root is n to the one
over log n.
OK, good, remember the
definition of having a power,
A to the B?
It was like two to the power,
B log A?
Does that sound familiar?
So, this is two to the log n
over log n, which is,
I hope you can get it at this
point, two.
Wow, so the log n'th root of n
minus two is zero:
my favorite answer.
OK, this is to.
So this whole thing is two log
n: pretty nifty.
So, you could be a little
fancier and tweak this a little
bit, but two log n is plenty
good for me.
We clearly don't want to use
any more lists,
but log n lists sounds pretty
good.
I get, now, logarithmic search
time.
Let's check.
I mean, we sort of did this all
intuitively.
Let's draw what the list looks
like.
But, it will work.
So, I'm going to redraw this
example because you have to,
also.
So, let's redesign that New
York City subway system.
And, I want you to leave three
blank lines up here.
So, you should have this
memorized by now.
But I don't.
So, we are not allowed to
change the local line,
though it would be nice,
add a few more stops there.
OK, we can stop at 79th Street.
That's enough.
So now, we have log n lists.
And here, log n is about four.
So, I want to make a bunch of
lists here.
In particular,
14 will appear on all of them.
So, why don't I draw those in?
And, the question is,
which elements go in here?
So, I have log n lists.
And, my goal is to balance the
number of items up here,
and the ratio between these two
lists, and the ratio between
these two lists,
and the ratio between these two
lists.
I want all these things to be
balanced.
There are log n of them.
So, the product of all those
ratios better be n,
the number of elements down
here.
So, the product of all these
ratios is n.
And there's log n of them;
how big is each ratio?
So, I'll call the ratio r.
The ratio's r.
I should have r to the power of
log n equals n.
What's r?
What's r minus two?
Zero.
OK, this should be two to the
power of log n.
So, if the ratio between the
number of elements here and here
is to all the way down,
then I will have an elements at
the bottom, which is what I
want.
So, in other words,
I want half the elements here,
a quarter of the elements here,
an eighth of the elements here,
and so on.
So, I'm going to take half of
the elements evenly spaced out:
34th, 50th, 66th,
79th, and so on.
So, this is our new
semi-express line:
not terribly fast,
but you save a factor of two
for going up there.
And, when you're done,
you go down,
and you walk,
at most, one step.
And you find what you're
looking for.
OK, and then we do the same
thing over and over and over
until we run out of elements.
I can't read my own writing.
It's 79th.
OK, if I had a bigger example,
I would be more levels,
but this is just barely enough.
Let's say two elements is where
I stop.
So, this looks good.
Does this look like a structure
you've seen before,
at all, vaguely?
Yes?
A tree: yes.
It looks a lot like a binary
tree.
I'll just leave it at that.
In your problem set,
you'll understand why skip
lists are really like trees.
But it's more or less a tree.
Let's say at this level,
it looks sort of like binary
search.
You look at 14;
you look at 15,
and therefore,
you decide whether you are in
the left half for the right
half.
And that's sort of like a tree.
It's not quite a tree because
we have this element repeated
all over.
But more or less,
this is a binary tree.
At depth I, we have two to the
I nodes, just like a tree,
just like a balanced tree.
I'm going to call this
structure an ideal skip list.
And, if all we are doing our
searches, ideal skip lists are
pretty good.
Maybe at practice:
not quite as good as a binary
search tree, but up to constant
factors: just as good.
So, for example,
I mean, we can generalize
search, just check that it's log
n.
So, the search procedure is you
start at the top left.
So, let's say we are looking
for 72.
You start at the top left.
14 is smaller than 72,
so I try to go right.
79 is too big.
So, I follow this arrow,
but I say, oops,
that's too much.
So, instead,
I go down 14 still.
I go to the right:
oh, 50, that's still smaller
than 72: OK.
I tried to go right again.
Oh: 79, that's too big.
That's no good.
So, I go down.
So, I get 50.
I do the same thing over and
over.
I try to go to the right:
oh, 66, that's OK.
Try to go to the right:
oh, 79, that's too big.
So I go down.
Now I go to the right and,
oh, 72: done.
Otherwise, I'd go too far and
try to go down and say,
oops, element must not be
there.
It's a very simple search
algorithm: same as here except
just remove the L_1 and L_2.
Go right until that would go
too far.
Then go down.
Then go right until we'd go too
far, and then go down.
You might have to do this log n
times.
In each level,
you're clearly only walking a
couple of steps because the
ratio between these two sizes is
only two.
So, this will cost two log n
for search.
Good, I mean,
so that was to check because we
were using intuition over here;
a little bit shaky.
So, this is an ideal skip list,
we have to support insertions
and deletions.
As soon as we do an insert and
delete, there's no way we're
going to maintain the structure.
It's a bit too special.
There is only one of these
where everything is perfectly
spaced out, and everything is
beautiful.
So, we can't do that.
We're going to maintain roughly
this structure as best we can.
And, if anyone of you knows
someone in New York City subway
planning, you can tell them
this.
OK, so: skip lists.
So, I mean, this is basically
our data structure.
You could use this as a
starting point,
but then you start using skip
lists.
And, we need to somehow
implement insertions and
deletions, and maintain roughly
this structure well enough that
the search still costs order log
n time.
So, let's focus on insertions.
If we do insertions right,
it turns out deletions are
really trivial.
And again, this is all from
first principles.
We're not allowed to use
anything fancy.
But, it would be nice if we
used some good chalk.
This one looks better.
So, suppose you want to insert
an element, x.
We said how to search for an
element.
So, how do we insert it?
Well, the first thing we should
do is figure out where it goes.
So, we search for x.
We call search of x to find
where x fits in the bottom list,
not just any list.
Pretty easy to find out where
it fits in the top list.
That takes, like,
constant time.
What we want to know:
because the top list has
constant length,
we want to know where x goes in
the bottom list.
So, let's say we want to insert
a search for 80.
Well, it is a bit too big.
Let search for 75.
So, we'll find the 75 fits
right here between 72 and 79
using the same path.
OK, if it's there already,
we complain because I'm going
to assume all keys are distinct
for now just so the picture
stays simple.
But this works fine even if you
are inserting the same key over
and over.
So, that seems good.
One thing we should clearly do
is insert x into the bottom
list.
We now know where it fits.
It should go there.
Because we want to maintain
this invariant,
that the bottom list contains
all the elements.
So, there we go.
We've maintained the invariant.
The bottom list contains all
the elements.
So, we search for 75.
We say, oh, 75 goes here,
and we just sort of link in 75.
You know how to do a linked
list, I hope.
Let me just erase that pointer.
All the work in implementing
skip lists is the linked list
manipulation.
Is that enough?
No, it would be fine for now
because now there's only a chain
of length three here that you'd
have to walk over if you're
looking for something in this
range.
But if I just keep inserting
75, and 76, than 76 plus
epsilon, 76 plus two epsilon,
and so on, just pack a whole
bunch of elements in here,
this chain will get really
long.
Now, suddenly,
things are not so balanced.
If I do a search,
I'll pay an arbitrarily long
amount time here to search for
someone.
If I insert k things,
it'll take k time.
I want it to stay log n.
If I only insert log n items,
it's OK for now.
What I want to do is decide
which of these lists contain 75.
So, clearly it goes on the
bottom.
Every element goes in the
Should it go up a level?
Maybe.
It depends.
It's not clear yet.
If I insert a few items here,
definitely some of them should
go on the next level.
Should I go to levels up?
Maybe, but even less likely.
So, what should I do?
Yeah?
Right, so you maintain the
ideal partition size,
which may be like the length of
this chain.
And you see,
well, if that gets too long,
then I should split it in the
middle, promote that guy up to
the next level,
and do the same thing up here.
If this chain gets too long
between two consecutive next
level express stops,
then I'll promote the middle
guy.
And that's what you'll do in
your problem set.
That's too fancy for me.
I don't need no stinking
counters.
What else could I do?
I could try to maintain the
ideal skip list structure.
That will be too expensive.
Like I say, 75 is the guy that
gets promoted,
and this guy gets demoted all
the way down.
But that will propagate
everything to the right.
And that could cost linear time
for update.
Other idea?
If I only want half of them to
go up, I could flip a coin.
Good idea.
All right, for that,
I will give you a quarter.
It's a good one.
It's the old line state,
Maryland.
There you go.
However, you have to perform
some services for that quarter,
namely, flip the coin.
Can you flip a coin?
Good.
What did you get?
Tails, OK, that's the first
random bit.
But we are going to do is build
a skip list.
Maybe I should tell you how
first.
OK, but the idea is flip a
coin.
If it's heads,
so, sorry, if it's heads,
we will promote it to the next
level, and flip again.
So, this is an answer to the
question, which other lists
should store x?
How many other lists should we
add x to?
Well, the algorithm is,
flip a coin,
and if it comes out heads,
then promote x.
to the next level up,
and flip again.
OK, that's key because we might
want this element to go
arbitrarily high.
But for starters,
we flip a coin.
It doesn't go to the next
level.
Well, we'd like it to go to the
next level with probability one
half because we want the ratio
between these two sizes to be a
half, or sorry,
two, depending which way you
take the ratio.
So, I want roughly half the
elements up here.
So, I flip a coin.
If it comes up heads,
I go up here.
This is a fair coin.
So I want it 50-50.
OK, then how many should that
element go up to the next level
up?
Well, with 50% probability
again.
So, I flip another point.
If it comes up heads,
I'll go up another level.
And that will maintain the
approximate ratio between these
two guys as being two.
The expected ratio will
definitely be two,
and so on, all the way up.
If I go up to the top and flip
a coin, it comes up heads,
I'll make another level.
This is the insertion
algorithm: dead simple.
The fancier one you will see on
your problem set.
So, let's do it.
OK, I also need someone to
generate random numbers.
Who can generate random
numbers?
Pseudo-random?
I'll give you a quarter.
I have one here.
Here you go.
That's a boring quarter.
Who would like to generate
random numbers?
Someone volunteering someone
else: that's a good way to do
it.
Here you go.
You get a quarter,
but you're not allowed to flip
it.
No randomness for you;
well, OK, you can generate
bits, and then compute a number.
So, give me a number.
44, can answer.
OK, we already flipped a coin
and I got tails.
Done.
That's the insertion algorithm.
I'm going to make some more
space actually,
put it way down here.
OK, so 44 does not get promoted
because we got a tails.
So, give me another number.
Nine, OK, I search for nine in
this list.
I should mention one other
thing, sorry.
I need a small change.
This is just to make sure
searches still work.
So, the worry is suppose I
insert something bigger and then
I promote it.
This would look very bad for a
skip list data structure because
I always want to start at the
top left, and now there's no top
left.
So, just minor change:
just let me remember that.
The minor change is that I'm
going to store a special value
minus infinity in every list.
So, minus infinity always gets
promoted all the way to the top,
whatever the top happens to be
now.
So, initially,
that way I'll always have a top
left.
Sorry, I forgot to mention
that.
So, initially I'll just have
minus infinity.
Then I insert 44.
I say, OK, 44 goes there,
no promotion,
done.
Now, we're going to insert
nine.
Nine goes here.
So, minus infinity to nine,
flip your coin,
heads.
Did he actually flip it?
OK, good.
He flipped it before,
yeah, sure.
I'm just giving you a hard
time.
So, we have nine up here.
We need to maintain this minus
infinity just to make sure it
gets promoted along with
everything else.
So, that looks like a nice skip
list.
Flip it again.
Tails, good.
OK, so this looks like an ideal
skip list.
Isn't that great?
It works every time.
OK, give me another number.
26, OK, so I search for 26.
26 goes here.
It clearly goes on the bottom
list.
Here we go, 26,
and then I you raised 44.
Flip.
Tails, OK, another number.
50, oh, a big one.
It costs me a little while to
search, and I get over here.
Flip.
Heads, good.
So 50 gets promoted.
Flip it again.
Tails, OK, still a reasonable
number.
Another number?
12, it takes a little while to
get exciting here.
OK, 12 goes here between nine
and 26.
You're giving me a hard time
here.
OK, flip.
Heads, OK, 12 gets promoted.
I know you have to work a
little bit, but we just came
here to search for 12.
So, we know that nine was the
last point we went down.
So, we promote 12.
It gets inserted up here.
We are just inserting into this
particular linked list:
nothing fancy.
We link the two twelves
together.
It still looks kind of like a
linked list.
Flip again.
OK, tails, another number.
Jeez.
It's a good test of memory.
37, what was it,
44 and 50?
And 50 was at the next level
up.
I think I should just keep
appending elements and have you
flip coins.
OK, we just inserted 37.
Tails.
OK, that's getting to be a long
chain.
That looks a bit worse.
OK, give me another number
larger than 50.
51, good answer.
Thank you.
OK, flip again.
And again.
Tails.
Another number.
Wait, someone else should pick
a number.
It's not working.
What did you say?
52, good answer.
Flip.
Tails, not surprising.
We've gotten a lot of heads
there.
OK, another number.
53, thank you.
Flip.
Heads, heads,
OK.
you didn't flip.
All right, 53,
you get the idea.
If you get two consecutive
heads, then the guy goes up two
levels.
OK, now flip for real.
Heads.
Finally.
Heads we've been waiting for.
If you flipped three heads in a
row, you go three levels.
And each time,
we keep promoting minus
infinity.
Look again.
Heads, oh my God.
Where were they before?
Flip again.
It better be tails this time.
Tails, good.
OK, you get the idea.
Eventually you run out of board
space.
Now, it's pretty rare that you
go too high.
What's the probability that you
go higher than log n?
Another easy log computation.
Each time, I have a 50%
probability of going up.
One in n probability of going
up log n levels because half to
the power of log n is one out of
n.
So, it depends on n,
but I'm not going to go too
high.
And, intuitively,
this is not so bad.
So, these are skip lists.
You have the ratios right in
expectation, which is a pretty
weak statement.
This doesn't say anything about
the lengths of these change.
But intuitively,
it's pretty good.
Let's say pretty good on
average.
So, I had two semi-random
processes going on here.
One is picking the numbers,
and that, I don't want to
assume anything about.
The numbers could be
adversarial.
It could be sequential.
It could be reverse sorted.
It could be random.
I don't know.
So, it didn't matter what he
said.
At least, it shouldn't matter.
I mean, it matters here.
Don't worry.
You're still loved.
You still get your $0.25.
But what the algorithm cares
about is the outcomes of these
coins.
And the probability,
the statement that this data
structure is fast with high
probability is only about the
random coins.
Right, it doesn't matter what
the adversary chooses for
numbers as long as those coins
are random, and the adversary
doesn't know the coins.
It doesn't know the outcomes of
the coins.
So, in that case,
on average, overall of the coin
flips, you should be OK.
But the claim is not just that
it's pretty good on average.
But, it's really,
really good almost always.
OK, with really high
probability it's log n.
So, for example,
with probability,
one minus one over n,
it's order of log n,
with probability one minus one
over n^2 it's log n,
probability one minus one over
n^100, it's order log n.
All those statements are true
for any value of 100.
So, that's where we're going.
OK, I should mention,
how do you delete in a skip
list?
Find the element.
You delete it all the way.
There's nothing fancy with
delete.
Because we have all these
independent, random choices,
all of these elements are sort
of independent from each other.
We don't really care.
So, delete an element,
just throw it away.
The tricky part is insertion.
When I insert an element,
I'm just going to randomly see
how high it should go.
With probability one over two
to the i, it will go to height
i.
Good, that's my time.
I've been having too much fun
here.
I've got to go a little bit
faster, OK.
So here's the theorem.
Let's see exactly what we are
proving first.
With high probability,
this is a formal notion which I
will define a second.
Every search in n elements skip
lists costs order of log n.
So, that's the theorem.
Now I need to define with high
probability.
So, with high probability.
And, it's a bit of a long
phrase.
So, often we will,
and you can abbreviate it WHP.
So, if I have a random event,
and the random event here is
that every search in an n
element skip list costs order
log n, I want to know what it
means for that event E to occur
with high probability.
So this is the definition.
So, the statement is that for
any alpha greater than or equal
to one, there is a suitable
choice of constants --
-- for which the event,
E, occurs with this probability
I keep mentioning.
So, the probability at least
one minus one over n to the
alpha.
So, this is a bit imprecise,
but it will suffice for our
purposes.
If you want to really formal
definition, you can read the
lecture notes.
There are special lecture notes
for this lecture on the stellar
site.
And, there's the PowerPoint
notes on the SMA site.
But, right, there's a bit of a
subtlety in the choice of
constants here.
There is a choice of this
constant.
And there's a choice of this
And, these are related.
And, there's alpha,
which we get to whatever we
want.
But the bottom line is,
we get to choose what
probability we want this to be
true.
If I want it to be true,
with probability one minus one
over n^100, I can do that.
I just sat alpha to a hundred,
and up to this little constant
that's going to grow much slower
than n to the alpha.
I get the error probability.
So this thing is called the
error probability.
The probability that I fail is
polynomially small,
for any polynomial I want.
Now, with the same data
structure, right,
I fixed the data structure.
It doesn't depend on alpha.
Anything you want,
any alpha value you want,
this data structure will take
order of log n time.
Now, this constant will depend
on alpha.
So, you know,
you want error probability one
over n^100 is probably going to
be, like, 100 log n.
It's still log n.
OK, this is a very strong claim
about the tale of the
distribution of the running time
of search, very strong.
Let me give you an idea of how
strong it is.
How many people know what
Boole's inequality is?
How many people know what the
union bound is in probability?
You should.
It's in appendix c.
Maybe you'll know it by the
theorem.
It's good to know it by name.
It's sort of like linearity of
expectations.
It's a lot easier to
communicate to someone.
Linearity of expectations:
instead of saying,
you know that thing where you
sum up all the expectations of
things, and that's the
expectation of the sum?
It's a lot easier to say
linearity of expectation.
So, let me quiz you in a
different way.
So, if I take a bunch of
events, and I take their union,
either this happens or this
happens, or so on.
So, this is the inclusive OR of
k events.
And, instead,
I look at the sum of the
probabilities of those events.
OK, easy question:
are these equal?
No, unless they are
independent.
But can I say anything about
them, any relation?
Smaller, yeah.
This is less than or equal to
that.
OK, this should be intuitive to
you from a probability point of
view.
Look at the textbook.
OK: very basic result,
trivial result almost.
What does this tell us?
Well, suppose that E_i is some
kind of error event.
We don't want it to happen.
OK, and suppose,
mix some letters here.
Suppose I have a bunch of
events which occur with high
probability.
OK, call those E_i complement.
So, suppose,
so this is the end of that
statement, E_i complement occurs
with high probability.
OK, so then the probability of
E_i is very small,
polynomially small.
One over n to the alpha for any
alpha I want.
Now, suppose I take a whole
bunch of these events,
and let's say that k is
polynomial in n.
So, I take a bunch of events,
which I'd like to happen.
They all occur with high
probability.
There is only polynomially many
of them.
So let's say,
let me give this constant a
name.
Let's call it c.
Let's say I take n to the c
such events.
Well, what's the probability
that all those events occur
together?
Because they should rest of the
time occurred together because
each one occurs most of the
time, occurs with high
probability.
So, I want to look at E_1 bar
intersect, E_2 bar,
and so on.
So, each of these occurs as
high probability.
What's the chance that they all
occur?
It's also with high
probability.
I'm changing the alpha.
So, the union bound tells me
the probability of any one of
these failing,
the probability of this
failing, or this failing,
or this failing,
which is this thing,
is, at most,
the sum of the probabilities of
each failure.
These are the error
probabilities.
I know that each of them is,
at most, one over n to the
alpha, with a constant in front.
If I add them all up,
there's only n to the c of
them.
So, I take this error
probability, and I multiply by n
to the c.
So, I get like n to the c over
n to the alpha,
which is one over n to the
alpha minus c.
I can set alpha as big as I
want.
So, I said it much,
much bigger than c,
and this event occurs with high
probability.
I sort of made a mess here,
but this event occurs with high
probability because of this.
Whatever the constant is here,
however many events I'm taking,
I just set alpha to be bigger
than that.
And, this event will occur with
high probability,
too.
So, when I say here that every
search of cost order log n with
high probability,
not only do I mean that if you
look at one search,
it costs order log n with high
probability.
You look at another search,
and it costs log n with high
probability.
I mean, if you take every
search, all of them take order
log n time with high
probability.
So, this event that every
single search you do takes order
log n, is true with high
probability estimate the number
of searches you are doing is
polynomial in n.
So, I'm assuming that I'm not
using this data structure
forever, just for a polynomial
amount of time.
But, who's got more than a
polynomial amount of time
anyway?
This is MIT.
So, hopefully that's clear.
We'll see it a few more times.
Yeah?
The algorithm doesn't depend on
Alpha.
The question is how do you
choose alpha in the algorithm.
So, we don't need to.
This is just sort of for an
analysis tool.
This is saying that the farther
out you get, so you say,
well, what's the probability
that more than ten log n.
Well, it's like one over n^10.
Let's say it's linear.
Well, what's the chance that
you're more than 20 log n?
Well that's one over n^20.
So, the point is the tail of
this distribution is getting a
really small,
really fast.
And, such using alpha is more
like sort of for your own
feeling good.
OK, you can set it to 100,
and then n is at least two.
So, that's like one over 2^100
chance that you fail.
That's damn small.
If you've got a real random
number generator,
the chance that you're going to
hit one over 2^200 is pretty
tiny, right?
So, let's say you set alpha to
256, which is always a good
number.
2^256 is much bigger than the
number of particles in the known
universe, so,
the light matter.
So, actually I think this even
accounts for some notion of dark
matter.
So, this is really,
really, really big.
So, the chance that you pick a
random particle in the universe
that happens to be your favorite
particle, this one right here,
that's over one over 2^256,
or even smaller.
So, set alpha to 256,
the chance to your algorithm
takes more than order log n time
is a lot smaller than the chance
that a meteor strikes your
computer at the same time that
it has a flooding point error,
at the same time that the earth
explodes because they're putting
a transport through this part of
the solar system at the same
time, I mean,
I could go on,
right?
It's really,
really unlikely that you are
more than log n.
And how unlikely:
you get to choose.
But it's just in the analysis
the algorithm doesn't depend on
it.
It's the same algorithm,
very cool.
Sometimes, with high
probability, bounds depends on
alpha.
I mean, the algorithm depends
on alpha.
But here, it will not.
OK, away we go.
So now you all understand the
claim.
So let's do a warm up.
We will also need this fact.
But it's pretty easy.
The lemma is that with high
probability, the number of
levels in the skip list is order
log n.
I think it's order log n,
certainly.
So, how do we prove that
something happens with high
probably?
Compute the probability that it
happened; show that it's high.
Even if you don't know what
high probability means,
in fact, I used to ask that
earlier on.
So, let's compute the chance
that it doesn't happen,
the error probability,
because that's just a one minus
the cleaner.
So, I'd like to say,
let's say, that it's,
at most, c log n levels.
So, what's the error
probability for that event?
This is sort of an event.
I'll put it in squiggles just
for, all set.
This is the probability that
they are strictly greater than c
log n levels.
So, I want to say that that
probability is particularly
small, polynomially small.
Well, how do I make levels?
When I insert an element,
the probability half,
it goes up.
And, the number of levels in
the skip list is the max over
all the elements of how high it
goes up.
But, max, oh,
that's a mess.
All right, you can compute the
expectation of the max if you
have a bunch of unknown
variables; there is expectation
there is a constant,
and you take the max.
It's like log in and
expectation, but we want a much
stronger statement.
And, we have this Boole's
inequality that says I have a
bunch of things,
polynomially many things.
Let's say we have n items.
Each one independently,
I don't even care if it's a
dependent.
If it goes up more than c log
n, yeah, the number of levels is
more than c log n.
So, this is,
at most, and then I want to
know, do any of those events
happen for any of the n
elements?
So, I just multiplied by n.
It's certainly,
at most, n times the
probability that x gets
promoted, this much here,
greater than or equal to log n
times.
OK, if I pick,
for any element,
x, because it's the same for
each element.
They are done independently.
So, I'm just summing over x
here, and that's just a factor
of n.
Clear?
This is Boole's inequality.
Now, what's the probability
that x gets promoted c log n
times?
We did this before for log n.
It was one over n.
For c log n,
it's one over n to the c.
OK, this is n times two.
Let's be nicer:
one half to the power of c log
n.
One half to the power of c log
n is one over two to the c log
n.
The log n comes out here,
becomes an n.
We get n to the c.
So, this is n divided by n to
the c, which is n to the c minus
one.
And, I get to choose c to be
whatever I want.
So, I choose c minus one to be
alpha.
I think exactly that.
Oh, sorry, one over n to the c
minus one.
Thank you.
It better be small.
This is an upper bound.
So, probability is polynomially
small.
I get to choose,
and this is a bit of the trik.
I'm choosing this constant to
be large, large enough for
alpha.
The point is,
as c grows, alpha grows.
Therefore, I can set alpha to
be whatever I want,
set c accordingly.
So, there's a little bit more
words that have to go here.
But, they're in the notes.
I can set alpha to be as large
as I want.
So, I can make this probability
as small as I want in the
polynomial sets.
So, that's it.
Number of levels,
order log n:
wasn't that easy?
Rules and equality,
the point is that when you're
dealing with high probability,
use Boole's inequality.
And, anything that's true for
one element is true for all of
them, just like that.
Just lose a factor of n,
but that's just one in the
alpha, and alpha is big:
big constant,
but it's big.
OK, so let's prove the theorem.
High probability searches cost
order log n.
We now know the height is order
log n, but it depends how
balanced this thing is.
It depends how long the chains
are to really know that a search
costs log n.
Just knowing a bound on the
height is not enough,
unlike a binary tree.
So, we have one cool idea for
this analysis.
And it's called backwards
analysis.
So, normally you think of a
search as starting in the top
left corner going left and down
until you get to the item that
you're looking for.
I'm going to look at the
reverse process.
You start at the item you're
looking for, and you go left and
up until you get to the top left
corner.
The number of steps in those
two walks is the same.
And, I'm not implementing an
algorithm here,
I'm just doing analysis.
So, those are the same
processes, just in reverse.
So, here's what it looks like.
You have a search,
and it starts,
which really means that it ends
at a node in the bottom list.
Then, each time you visit a
node in this search,
you either go left or up.
And, when do you go left or up?
Well, it depends with the coin
flip was.
So, if the node wasn't promoted
at this level.
So, if it wasn't promoted
higher, and that happened
exactly when we got a tails.
Then, we go left,
which really means we came from
the left.
Or, if we got a heads,
so if this node was promoted to
the next level,
which happened whenever we got
a heads at that particular
moment.
This is in the past some time
when we did the insertion.
Then we go, or came from,
up.
And, we stop at the root.
This is really where we start;
same thing.
So, either at the root or I'm
also going to think of this as
stopping at minus infinity.
OK, that was a bit messy,
but let me review.
So, normally we start up here.
Well, just looking at
everything backwards,
and in brackets is what's
really happening.
So, this search ends at the
node you were looking for.
It's always in the bottom list.
Then it says,
well, was this node promoted
higher?
If it was, I came from above.
If not, I came to the left.
It must have been in the bottom
chain somewhere.
OK, and that's true at every
node you visit.
It depends whether that quite
slipped heads or tails at the
time that you inserted that node
into that level.
But, these are just a bunch of
events.
I'm just going to check,
what is the probability that
its heads, and what is the
probability that a tails?
It's always a half.
Every time I look at a coin
flip, when it was flipped,
there was a probability of half
going out of their way.
That's the magic.
And, I'm not using that these
events are independent anyway.
For every element that I search
for, for every value,
x, that's another search.
Those events may not be
independent.
I can still use Boole's
inequality and conclude that all
of them are order log n with
high probability.
As long as I can prove that any
one event happens with high
probability.
So, I don't need independence
between, I knew that these coin
flips in a single search are
independent, but everything
else, for different searches I
don't care.
So, how long can this process
go on?
We want to know how many times
can I make this walk?
Well, when I hit the root node,
I'm done.
Well, how quickly would I hit
the root node?
Well, with probability,
a half, I go up each step.
The number of times I go up is,
at most, the number of levels
minus one.
And that's order log n with
high probability.
So, this is the only other
idea.
So, we are now improving this
theorem.
So, the number of up moves in a
search, which are really down
moves, but same thing,
is less than the number of
levels.
Certainly, you can't go up more
than there are levels in the
search.
And in insert,
you can go arbitrarily high.
But a search:
as high as you can go.
And this is,
at most, c log n with high
probability.
This is what we proved in the
lemma.
So, we have a bound on the
number of up moves.
Half of the moves,
roughly, are going to be up
moves.
So, this pretty much down to
the number of moves.
Not quite.
So, what this means is that
with high probability,
so this is the same
probability, but I could choose
that as high as I want by
setting c large enough.
The number of moves,
in other words,
the cost of the search is at
most the number of coin flips
until we get c long n heads,
right, because in every step of
the search, I make a move,
and then I flip another coin,
conceptually.
There is another independent
coin lying there.
And it's either heads or tails.
Each of those is independent.
So, how many independent coin
flips does it take until I get c
log n heads?
The claim is that that's order
log n with high probability.
But we need to prove that.
So, this is a claim.
So, if you just sit there with
a coin, and you want to know how
many times does it take until I
get c log n heads,
the claim is that that number
is order log n with high
probability.
As long as I prove that,
I know that the total number of
steps I make,
which is the number of heads
and tails is order log n because
I definitely know the number of
heads is, at most,
c log n.
The claim is that the number of
tails can't be too much bigger.
Notice, I can't just say c
here.
OK, it's really important that
I have log n.
Why?
Because with high probability,
it depends on n.
This notion depends on n.
Log n: it's true.
Anything bigger that log n:
it's true, like n.
If I put n here,
this is also true.
But, if I put a constant or a
log log n, this is not true.
It's really important that I
have log n here because my
notion of high probability
depends on what's written here.
OK, it's clear so far.
We're almost done,
which is good because I just
ran out of time.
Sorry, we're going to go a
couple minutes over.
So, I want to compute the error
probability here.
So, I want to compute the
probability that there is less
than c log n heads.
Let me skip this step.
So, I will be approximate and
say, what's the probability that
there is, at most,
c log n heads?
So, I need to say how many
coins we are flipping here for
what this event is.
So, I need to specify this
constant.
Let's say we flip ten c log n
coins.
Now I want to look at the error
probability under that event.
The probability that there is
at most c log n heads among
those ten c log n flips.
So, the claim is this should be
pretty small.
It's going to depend on ten.
Then I'll choose ten to be
arbitrarily large,
and I'll be done,
OK, make my life a little bit
easier.
Well, I would ask you normally,
but this is 6.042 material.
So, what's the probability that
we have, at most,
this many heads?
Well, that means that nine c
log n of the coins,
because there are ten c log n
flips, c log n heads at most,
nine c log n at least better be
tails.
So this is the probability that
all those other guys become
tails, which is already pretty
small.
And then, there is this
permutation thing.
So, if I had exactly c log n
heads, this would be the number
of ways to rearrange c log n
heads among ten c log n coin
flips.
OK, that's just the number of
permutations.
So, this is a bit big,
which is kind of annoying.
This is really,
really small.
The claim is this is much
smaller than that is big.
So, this is just some math.
I'm going to whiz through it.
So, you don't have to stay too
long.
But you should go over it.
You should know that y choose x
is, at most, ey over x to the x,
good fact.
Therefore, this is,
at most, ten c log n over c log
n, also known as ten.
These cancel.
There's an e out here.
And then I raise that to the c
log n power.
OK, then I divide by two to the
power, nine c log n.
OK, so what's this?
This is e times ten to the c
log n divided by two to the nine
c log n.
OK, claim this is very big.
This is not so big,
because I have a nine here.
So, let's work it out.
This e times ten,
that's a good number,
we can put upstairs.
So, we get log of e times ten,
ten times, e,
and then c log n.
And then, we have over two to
the nine c log n.
So, we have this two to the c
log n in both cases.
So, this is two to the log,
ten e minus nine,
c, log n: some basic algebra.
So, I'm going to set,
not quite.
This is one over two to the
nine minus log:
so, just inverting everything
here, negating the sign in here.
And, this is my alpha because
the rest is n.
So, this is one over n to the
alpha when alpha is this
particular value:
nine minus log of ten times e
times c.
It's a bit of a strange thing.
But, the point is,
as ten goes to infinity,
nine here is the number one
smaller than ten,
right?
We subtracted one somewhere
along the way.
So, as ten goes to infinity,
this is basically,
this is ten minus one.
This is log of ten times e.
e doesn't really matter.
The point is,
this is logarithmic in ten.
This is linear in ten.
The thing that's linear in ten
is much bigger than the thing
that's logarithmic in ten.
This is called abusive
notation.
OK, as ten goes to infinity,
this goes to infinity,
gets bigger.
And, there is a c out here.
But, for any value of c that
you want, whatever value of c
you wanted in that claim,
I can make alpha arbitrarily
large by changing the constant
in the big O,
which here was ten.
OK, so that claim is true with
high probability.
Whatever probability you want,
which tells you alpha,
you set a constant effort of
the log N to be this number,
which grows,
and you're done.
You get the claim that is order
log N heads, order log N flips
with the high probability,
therefore.
[None of the steps?] in the
search is order log N with high
probability.
Really cool stuff;
read the notes.
Sorry I went so fast at the
end.